The short answer is that there is no 100%
definitive known reason as to why nails grow
at different rates.
However, there is a really good theory (which
also covers why fingernails and toenails grow
at drastically different rates) that is backed
up by an awful lot of ancillary evidence.
To fully grasp what’s going on here, it’s
important to understand exactly how your fingernails
grow.
Every type of cell in our body grows at different
rates.
For example, we know that hair grows faster
than bones and cancer grows faster than anyone
would like.
The exact mediating factor of what gives rise
to that growth rate is still the topic of
much research.
What we do know is that the answer lies in
our genes.
Now it should be noted that in August of 2012,
a team of researchers at MIT and the Harvard
Medical School were able to answer when mammalian
cells decide to divide.
They found that cells divide when they reach
a critical phase in development, not when
they reach a specific size.
This breakthrough in understanding will now
allow them to test the factors that determine
why they might grow and divide at those rates.
But as to finger and toenails, what we know
about fingernails is that they grow at a rate
of about 3.5 millimeters per month and toenails
grow about 1.6 mm per month on average.
The exact rate at which your nails will grow
depends on several factors.
They include things like: age, sex, diet,
exercise, and even the time of year.
Our nails consist of many different parts.
The visible part is known as the nail plate.
Below this is the nail bed.
The white, half-moon shaped part at the base
of your nail is called the lunula (also known
as the distal matrix).
The tissue over the top of the matrix is called
the cuticle, and the soft tissue directly
over your cuticle, is called the eponychium.
The nail itself is grown from the matrix (presumably
your big toe is “The One”).
It lies beneath the fingernail and extends
several millimeters into the finger.
90% of nail growth comes from here.
The matrix consists of epithelial cells (the
most common type of cells that make up numerous
things in our bodies, like skin) that grow
and divide.
These cells contain proteins called keratin.
Once the cells begin to reach the end of their
life cycle, they go through a process called
Keratinization, also known as cornification.
When the cell dies, it loses its nucleus and
other intracellular organelles.
What remains is keratin.
It gets enclosed in an insoluble mixture of
different proteins and lipids (fats).
The enzyme responsible for this formation
is known as Transglutaminase.
The result is the hard nail used to pick noses
and give back scratches everywhere!
Pressure within the matrix of your nail forces
the dead karatinized cells out.
The shape of your nail, as it grows, is merely
a continuation of the angle of your matrix.
It’s then guided along by the nail grooves
and folds on the sides of your nail bed.
Keratinized cells are not just found in your
nails, but also in your hair, skin, and animal
hooves.
What makes them more hard, or soft, depends
on their thickness and the cross-linked structure
of the keratin.
Now that we know how our nails grow, let’s
get back to the specific question at hand
and talk about the main theories behind why
fingernails grow faster than toenails and
why nails on different fingers or toes grow
at different rates.
In the end, it really just seems to come down
to blood supply, but there’s a bit more
to it than just that certain fingers or toes
are getting a better and more oxygen rich
blood supply than others.
The matrix in our nails is supplied with blood
and nutrients through a highly vascular area
of capillaries.
They also have special shunts (blood pathways)
between the arteries and veins known as Sucquet-Hoyer
canals, that help regulate temperature in
your fingers and toes when it gets cold.
When any part of our body gets injured, the
natural reaction is a response that engorges
the area with more blood and nutrients.
So it is believed that the constant micro
trauma our fingernails endure throughout the
day, like tapping, typing, and bumping, allows
for an even greater increase in blood and
nutrient supply.
Since the toes are always kept locked away
safely in our socks and shoes (and in an office
like environment, we’re often immobile throughout
much of the day, but constantly using our
fingers as we type), they don’t receive
the constant “mini-trauma” that the fingernails
do.
Similarly, certain fingers and toes likely
get more trauma than others, affecting their
growth rate.
The end result of these micro traumas is a
chronic overabundance of nutrients that make
more karatinized epithelial cells.
The increase results in more nail.
The reason the “trauma” theory is adopted
by many researchers revolves around ancillary
evidence.
Fingernails on your dominant hand will grow
faster than the ones on your non-dominant
hand, presumably because your dominant hand
will have more micro trauma compared to your
non-dominant hand.
Additional ancillary evidence towards the
overarching “blood supply” theory is that
nails will grow faster in the summertime.
Since your fingers and toes are warmer, your
capillaries and arterioles are bigger, allowing
more blood-flow to the digits.
When circulation becomes an issue, like as
we age or in certain medical conditions like
diabetes, the nails will grow slower.